[موسيقى]
هذه حلقه الاستثنائيه وهذا ايضا مكان
الاستثنائي انه معرض اكتشف الجزيره الذي
خصصته هيئه متاحف قطر مشكوره بالتعاون مع
شبكه الجزيره لتصدير حقبه في تاريخ
الاعلام ليس العربيه فقط ولكن العالميه
ايضا هذا المعرض الذي يضم بين جنباته بعضا
من محطات هذا الصرح الاعلامي الذي بذل
ابناؤه وبناته من ارواحهم من اجل بقائه
صامدا امام محاولات النيل منه ومحاولات
التعتيم على الحقيقه وتكميم الافواه ليس
اخر هؤلاء الزميله شيرين ابو عقله التي
تخلد ذكرها ليس بين جنبات هذا المعرض فقط
ولكن في وجدان وقلوب الملايين شيرين
المراسله والصحفيه والانسانه تكريس لنضال
المراه في مجال الصحافه والاعلام ونحن
نقترب من اليوم العالمي للمراه نقف الليله
مع قصص لرفيقات الدرب في مهنه البحث عن
المتاعب والمتاعب مع نون النسوه مضاعفه
تتحدى فيها المراه واقعا وعقليه لا تزال
الى حد الان تستهل عمل المراه في الاعلام
هي التي اقتحمت الميدان في تغطيه تعقيدات
المشهد في منطقه تصنف دول عده فيها ضمن
الاخطر على الصحفيين منظمه مراسلون بلا
حدود تشير الى ان نحو 1700 صحفي قتلوا في
انحاء العالم ثلثهم في عالمنا العربي بين
عامي
2022 ومن بين ضحايا الصحافه وشهدائها خلال
العقدين الماضيين عشرات الصحفيات فضلا عن
تعرضهن لانتهاكات كالاعتقال والتحريض
والتهديد بالقتل والاغتصاب ومع هذا فان
رفيقات المهنه صامدات باسقات كالنخل في
حقل الاعلام في قصتنا حارسات الحقيقه
نتحدث الى غاليه حمد من فلسطين ونعائم
خالد من اليمن وليد ساهيلسم محرره الشؤون
الدوليه في القناه الرابعه البريطانيه عن
رؤيتهن بخصوصيه العمل الصحفي للمراه خاصه
في مناطق النزاعات والصعوبات التي تواجه
الصحفيات في بيئه العمل وفي محيطهن
الاجتماعي نستكمل بقيه هذه القصص مع
ضيفاتنا في هذه الحلقه في استوديو معرض
اكتشف الجزيره مع الزميلات ناديه العزوني
وهي صحفيه فرنسيه جزائريه الاصل مهتمه
بقضايا الاقليات والتنوع في فرنسا وعائشه
احمد باشا الصحفيه والمخرجه الصوماليه
التي تمثل جيلا جديدا من الصحفيين
والصحافيات الذين يحاولون مغالبه الهشاشه
السياسيه والاضطراب الامني في بلدانهم
ومعنا ايضا ايقونات فلسطين والجزيره
اللواتي تعذر للاسف حضورهن معنا هنا لكننا
نسعد باستضافتهن عبر الهواء مباشره
الزميله جيفارا المديري وزميل نجوان سمري
نسال الزميلات عن رؤيتهن للتحديات التي
تواجه عمل الصحافي كيف يمكن انهاء الافلات
من العقاب في الجرائم التي ترتكب بحقهن
وعن العقليات والمفاهيم السائده عن عملهن
في الاعلام لكن بدايه لنشاهد فيلم حارسات
الحقيقه ثم نبدا الحوار
[موسيقى]
هنا لم سوف نلتقي
جمهوريه مصر العربيه من القاهره
صوت فلسطين
اذاعه جمه
ور الاخبار من صوت لبنان فوجد اخر
[موسيقى]
ايات القرن التاسع عشر بدات اولى خطوات
بناء اللبنات الاساس لمشاركه الصحفيه
العربيه بالعمل الصحفي العربي ففي عام
1892 اسست الصحافيه هنوفل مجله الفتاه في
مصر تلاهى ظهور عشرات الصحف والمجلات
النسائيه في المنطقه العربيه التي اسستها
الصحفيات عربيه
وعلى الرغم من ذلك ففي واقعنا اليوم تشكل
النساء اقل من ثلث اجمالي عدد الصحافيين
في المنطقه العربيه طبقا لتقارير منظمه
اليونسكو ورغم نجاحهم بزياده نسبه تمثيلهن
في المجتمع الصحفي الا ان واقع الصحفيات
سواء عربيا او حتى عالميا لا يتناسب مع
دورهن ومع الانجازات التي حققناها على ارض
الواقع حيث لا يزالنا يواجهن العديد من
التحديات والعقبات في مسيرتهن المهنيه
[موسيقى]
عاشت خلال تغطيتها الصحفيه للهجمات
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه العديد من
الانتهاكات
من صعوبه عمل الصحفيه الفلسطينيه تحت
نيران الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من كل ايام
العدوان على غزه ممكن مره واحده نمت عند
بناتي
وبقيه الايام كنت بعيده عنهم وبس بتابع
اخبار القصف في منطقتهم
فكونك اخترتي ان تكوني صحفيه فانت تلقائيا
تنازلتي عن كثير من هدوءك الشخصي ومن
حياتك الشخصيه
واعطيتها للصحافه
مع هذه التطورات المتلاحقه
مليون
يطالب منا الخروج العرب
في فلسطين اشارت العديد من تقارير
المنظمات الدوليه الى تعرض الصحفيه
الفلسطينيه للعديد من الانتهاكات
والاعتداءات من قبل قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه والمستوطنين الاسرائيليين ففي
عام 2022
نقابه الصحفيين الفلسطينيين قتل الاحتلال
للصحفيتين شيرين ابو عقله وغفران وراسنا
واعتقاله للصحفيتين تحرير ابو سريه ولمى
ابو غوش كما وفقت 242 انتهاكا ضد الصحفيات
الفلسطينيه على يد قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
في اليمن التي صنفتها منظمه مراسلون بلا
حدود عام 2022
كاحد اسوا مناطق العمل الاعلامي في العالم
تواجه الصحفيه اليمنيه تحديات متعدده من
التمييز والتهديد وصعوبه الوصول الى
المعلومات بشكل امن
[موسيقى]
الصحفيه اليمنيه مع ام خالد تصف واقعهم
الصعب
بدات العمل طبعا في 2003 في هذه الفتره في
2003 كان في اسماء تظهر من البنات القائمه
من يشتغل في العالم الاعلام وفي الصحافه
المطلوبه وخصوصا الميدان انما اجدهم فتره
من الفتاه يختفن لا لشيء لان المجتمع
الذكوري كان طاغي بشكل
تعرضنا لاهانات واشياء غير عاديه في عملهم
[موسيقى]
كلها فيهالسن محرره الشؤون الدوليه في
القناه الرابعه البريطانيه عايشت بشكل
تفصيلي ظروف العمل الصحفي في الشرق الاوسط
الذي غطت احداثه لاكثر من عقدين من الزمن
لا اعتقد حقا ان تغطيه شؤون الشرق الاوسط
هو امر صعب على الصحفيات اكثر من الصحفيين
الذكور فاذا نظرت الى الصحفيين الذين
حققوا اداء جيدا في الشرق الاوسط ستجد ان
الكثير منهم من النساء الكثير من الصحفيات
البارعات اللواتي يغطينا الشرق الاوسط على
مر السنين كاميري كولفن واليسات وشيرين
ابو عاقله لذا لا يوجد فرق كبير في
التغطيه بين الجنسين لكن اظن ان هناك
حساسيه وادراكا اعمق لدى النساء عند
اجراءهم مقابلات صحفيه مع النساء او
الرجال ما يعطي تغطيه صحفيه افضل وهذا مهم
لا اريد ان اكون منحازه ضد الصحفيين
الذكور ولكن اعتقد ان هناك ما يتعلمونه
منا احيانا
[تصفيق]
اذكر انني في الحرب حرب الاخيره او قبل
الاخيره حرب 2021 كان في طفله ناجيه من
تحت الانقاض وكل الصحفيين كانوا بيحاولوا
يتكلموا معها وهي في حاله صدمه وذهول وما
بدها تتكلم مع حدا انا قربت منها ونسيت في
هاي اللحظه اني انا صحفيه كنت بتكلم معها
وبحاول اراضيها زي ما بحاول اراضي بنتي
بقولها حبيبتي اجيب لك عروسه عروسه لعبة
دميه فهزت راسها وحكت انا وقتها فرحت انه
اني انا قدرت اطلعها من السجن اللي هي فيه
الان العزله اللي هي عايشه فيها الداخليه
في كتير مواقف باشعر انه احس احس انه احنا
امهات انه احنا اناث ممكن يعطي للصوره
وللتغطيه عموما انسانيه اكبر
اتذكر حينما كنت بالقرب من بنغازي في
ليبيا حيث كانت قوات القذافي جاءني شاب
يشكو الي انه فقد جزءا من سلاحه وهو لا
يدري اين فقده فسالته كم عمرك اجابني 17
عاما حينها قلت في نفسي اتعلم والدتك انك
هنا وعلمت بعد ذلك ان هذا سؤال غريزي ولا
اعتقد ان رجلا كان سيساله
يحفزني انه كان في الحرب احيانا قذائف
تاتي على منازل البيوت كنت الوحيده اللي
اقدرني ادخل منازل ناس ادخل مع النساء
انقل المعاناه باريحيه لان النساء كانوا
تتقبلوا وجودي وكان بالنسبه للسهل
رغم الاضافات نوعيه التي تقدمها الصحفيات
في العمل الاعلامي المهني الا ان فجوه
المساواه بين الجنسين في المجال لا تزال
كبيره وهو ما يؤكده مشروع مراقبه وسائل
الاعلام العالميه
الذي يتتبع تهميش المراه في وسائل الاعلام
حيث يقول ان المؤسسات الاعلاميه التقليديه
تحتاج 67 عاما لسد متوسط فجوه المساواه
بين الجنسين فيها تقرير الجي ام ام بي
اوصى بان تتضمن المساواه بين الجنسين
تمثيل المراه في غرفه الاخبار ومواقع صنع
القرار وتضمين المواضيع التي تخصها في
المحتوى الاخبار باعتبارها فئه رئيسه بين
متابعيها
هناك مشاكل تواجه الصحفيات ليس في الشرق
الاوسط فحسب انما ايضا هنا في المملكه
المتحده كعدم الحصول على المناصب العليا
وعدم الحصول على اجور كاجور الرجال انها
مشاكل حقيقيه
يعني في الواقع عدم وجود المراه في اماكن
متقدمه من صنع القرار في المؤسسات الصحفيه
ربما يهمش في بعض الاحيان حقوقهن خصوصا
انه مش الجميع في مؤسسات تعتمد معايير
امان ومعايير سلامه قويه وواضحه ان شاء
الله
مشهد غياب المراه عن مواقع القرار برز في
تقرير للنقابه الوطنيه للصحفيين التونسيين
الصادر عام 2022 والذي اشار الى مفارقه
هامه فبينما تشكل النساء ما نسبته
54% من مجموع الصحفيين في تونس الا ان
نسبتهن في مواقع القرار لا تتعدى 15% مما
يجعل المشهد الاعلامي مؤنثا لكن القرار
مذكرا طبقا للتقرير
لكن ما يضاعف صعوبه المشهد الاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه التي تمر بها العديد من
الدول العربيه والتي انعكست سلبا على
الواقع الصحفي وكان اثرها اشد على
الصحفيات
[موسيقى]
الاعتمادات حقنا قليله جدا جدا لا تذكر
طبعا كل العمل اقوم به لوحدي اصور الحدث
اقوم باعداد التقرير او الخبر ايا كان حتى
البرامج اللي اشتغل فيها ايضا اعمل بعمليه
المونتاج بعد التصوير والاعداد اكمل
التقرير وكمان
ارسل ارفع الخبر التقرير كامل كما هو لانه
ما فيش معانا امكانيات هذا برضو انعكس على
حياتي الشخصيه على حياتي
كانسانه بغض النظر عن اعلاميه
احياء الايجارات مرتفعه اثرت علي الوضع
الاقتصادي اثرت عليه تاثير سلبي ومتعب
احنا الاعلاميات والحكوميات بالذات
والميدانيات نقول لهم انكم اصبحنا كمان
تعبانين
[موسيقى]
دفعت الاعلاميات ثمنا قاسيا لعملهم
الاعلامي فوافق تقرير مراسلون بلا حدود
لعام 2022 لقيت 81 صحفيه حتفه على مدار
العشرين سنه الماضيه ومنذ عام 2012 قتلت
52 صحفيه غالبيتهن على خلفيه التحقيق في
قضايا تتعلق بحقوق المراه وقد سجل ارتفاع
بحسب السنوات في اعداد النساء اللواتي
فارقنا الحياه نتيجه عملهن الاعلامي كان
بعضها مثيرا للقلق بشكل مهول حيث فقدت 10
صحفيات ارواحهم عام 2017 وهو معدل قياسي
مقارنه بباقي السنوات مره من المرات في
عمل الاعلامي وخصوصا في ايام الحرب ياتي
احدهم ويرفع عليها السلاح يقول لي لما
بطلتيش اعلام بوديك السائله بقتلك كان
موقف صعب بالنسبه لرجل يتهجم علي علشان
اوقف عم الاعلاميه اخذت السلاح وخفضته
وكنت اكابر على انني مش خايفه وعلشان ابعد
عن اقول له لا المراه لابد ان تكون موجوده
واللي براسك اعمله
لقد راينا ليس فقط في الشرق الاوسط ولكن
في كل العالم تهديدات رهيبه للصحفيات
بالقتل والاغتصاب اضافه الى المضايقات
التي تصلهن عبر المنصات الرقميه وقد راينا
ان الصحفيين الذكور قد يتعرضون للاساءه
ايضا الا ان الحال يبدو اسوا بكثير
بالنسبه الى الصحفيه
تمام
الوحده تتعرض الان الى هجمه عنيفه جدا
محيره بالمال الذي يعتبر الحي التجاري
والسوق الخاص بكل قطاع غزه الذي
قصف عنيف الان قطع الكهرباء عن كل الشارع
استطعنا ان نرى الضوء هذا القصف من مكاننا
حيث ربما يكون استهدافا من حيث
الحقيقه ما حدا فينا توقع انه ينجو من كل
حرب مرينا فيها
فهذا الدرع دائما بقول يا رب ما اضطر كمان
مره البسه يا رب كل فلسطين
[موسيقى]
بتنعتق من اللي بتمر فيه ومن القهر ومن
الماسي فلحتى ما نرجع نلبسه كمان مره
بتذكر كمان قديش هو ضعيف رغم انه
صنع
بجوده ودقه لكنه ضعيف
وانقتلت شيرين ابو عاقله وهي لابساه
وانقتل رامي ريان في غزه وهو لابسه
وغيرهم كتير كتير من زملائنا خالد حمد
وغيرهم من زملاء الصحفيين
[موسيقى]
خليك خليك بعلق تتحركي
شعرت بالفزع والمرض عندما قتلت شيرين لقد
كانت رمزا للنساء والرجال الذين تابعوها
في كل الشرق الاوسط التحقيقات في مقتل
الصحفيين مهمه واظن ان لها صدا حقيقيا في
المنطقه اعلم انه كانت هناك تحقيقات في
مقتلها
[موسيقى]
وقد التقطت الكاميرات لحظه اصابه الشيباني
برصاصه في راس اثناء عبوره احد الطرق اكثر
استشهاد احمد الشيباني كان مؤثر فيه تاثير
غير عادي خصوصا نحن رحنا المكان
نصور مش بايدينا اي اسلحه
كنا في حاله رعب حصار برصاصات قناصه
احتمال انه يكون اكثر من قناص واحتمال
لانه كانت متتاليه فوقنا
صاصا وصلت
ابني لكن مانيش وين وصلت للاسف وصلت دين
حمد الشيباني
الشباب ما خلونيش اقرب له عنده علشان يقدر
يسحبوا لنا انا كنت مستعده اروح اسحبه
هذا المكان اللي كنت اني باخسر فيه حياتي
وكمان حياتي اكثر من اغلب الاعلاميين
انطلقنا من هنا انا واحمد الشيباني وكان
الحوثي والقناصه في هذا الاتجاه ونحن نجري
في هذا الاتجاه اللي احنا فيه في دوله
المرور كان يوم صعب عشناه بتفاصيله ولكن
ما زال محفور داخلنا
[موسيقى]
النجاح دائما هو اللي يجعل من الخوف ومن
الرعب ومن ايضا من صعوبه الشيء هو اللي
يخليك مستمر وخصوصا انك تكون تحمل رساله
ورساله الاعلامي مش سهله وخصوصا الميداني
[موسيقى]
في خيار واحد امامك لما تكون صحفي انك
توصل صوت الناس والا صوتهم راح يختفي والا
معاناتهم ما حدا رح يعرف فيها فامامك خيار
خيارين اما ان تستمر
واما ان تستمر ما في خيار ثالث
يعطيكم العافيه
[موسيقى]
يعطيك الف صحه وعافيه يا غاليه ويعطيكم
الف صحه وعافيه زملاء الدرب نسائها
ورجالها نظل نقول العداله لشيرين لا
للافلات من العقاب
وتحيه لكل هؤلاء والنساء ورجالا الذين
يصرون على ايصال الحقيقه
للجميع كلمات الصحفيه الفلسطينيه غاليه
احمد من غزه عن الاصرار على ايصال صوت
الناس الى العالم في الواقع هي كلمات
سمعناها من قبل الزميله شيرين ابو عقله
ونرى نفس الاصرار في الواقع في بنات
فلسطين البطلات
اللواتي يواصلن هذه الرساله يسعدني ان
ارحب بضيفاتي هنا في الاستوديو ومن بينهن
طبعا
الزميله نجوان سمري مراسله الجزيره من رام
الله والزميله جيفارا المدير ايضا مراسله
الجزيره من
شكرا فيروز على هذه الاستضافه وشكرا
للجزيره على احتضان هذا العدد الكبير من
المراسلات والعاملات في غرفه الاخبار وكل
عام وكل نساء فلسطين والعالم بالف خير اول
شيء اصعب شيء اننا نتحدث من اصعب مكان
بالنسبه لي ولنجوان ولكل الزملاء
والزميلات وهي غرفه الشهيده الراحله شيرين
ابو عاقله شيرين التي تعد من اوائل
المراسلات الميدانيات اللواتي قدمنا كل
شيء لنقل الحقيقه ولنقل الصوره العمل
الميداني صعب جدا العمل ميداني ليس بالسهل
ولكن يعني لفتني اكثر من شيء بالفيلم الذي
تم عرضه قد نكون نوعا ما يحالفنا الحظ
اننا نعمل في فلسطين
اول شيء الارض خصبه
لتقبل المراه في العمل في الميدان كنا
نتحدث احيانا انا وشرين ونجوان عاده في اي
مجتمع عربي او شرقي عندما نرى امراه تخرج
في منتصف الليل وكانه شيء غريب ولكن هنا
كنا نرى خاصه في بدايه الانتفاضه 2000 عام
2005 انه عندما تخرج شيرين او جيفارا او
نجوان او غيرها من المراسلات على الفور
المواطن الفلسطيني يذهب الى التلفاز ليفتح
لانه يعرف ان هذه النساء يخرجن الان في
منتصف الليل يتركنا البيت يتركنا الحياه
الطبيعيه لنقل الواقع لنقل الاشتياح لنقل
هذه
الاعتداءات التي لا حصر لها المتواصله الى
اليوم العمل في الميدان ايضا هو صعب نحن
يعني من اصعب الاشياء اننا لا ندرك اننا
بنات لعائلات الام تخاف علينا امهاتنا
ابائنا ولكن ايضا الاصعب هو اطفالنا
بالنسبه لي للنجوان وكل الزملاء والزميلات
الوضع لا يختلف اطفالنا عم بخافوا يشوفوا
قناه الجزيره وخاصه من بعد شيرين يعني من
بعد 11 ايار الماضي كل شيء اختلف في
حياتنا ولكن هذا اعطانا اصرار في البدايه
كان اول ايام هو عباره عن رعب خوف لا ننكر
اننا فقدنا المعلمه والمدرسه ولكن كان
علينا ان ناخذ القرار اما ان نستمر او لا
نستمر بعد اعتداء مثلا الشيخ جراح والضرب
هو لم يكن فقط اعتداء نفسي او جسدي هو كان
ايصال رساله للجزيره اولا لمراسلاتها
مراسلينها طواقم الفنيين بانكم لن
تستطيعوا العمل بعد ذلك قصف مكتب غزه
لياتي في النهايه المصاب الاكبر والجلل
وهو اغتيال شيرين التي لم تحميها يعني
نتحدث عن اساليب الحمايه لم تحميها الرصاص
ولا الخوذه كان هناك قرار بالاختيال
باغتيال الكلمه والحقيقه ولكن يعني رغم كل
شيء تحدثت المراسله الاجنبيه والمراسلات
عن ان المراه تستطيع ان تقول الحقيقه اكثر
من الرجل احيانا لان هناك شعور عند المراه
الاحساس ايضا بشعورها كامراه كام انه في
شيء اكبر احيانا يكون السؤال الاصعب عندما
نذهب لام شهيد عاده الصحفيين يتسابقون
لاخذ امي الشهيد السؤال الاول ما شعورك
ابشع سؤال ان تسال امي الشهيد مثلا ما هو
شعورك يعني احيانا يعني الصعوبات بتكون
بين انه انت في نفس اللحظه بدك تفكر
بسلامه الطاقه بنقل الحقيقه
بالوصول للمعلومه بايصال الرساله بايصال
الكل يعني
عائلتك انه هل اطفالك في البيت عم بيشوفوك
ولا لا فكله يعني يتداخل في بعض
ذلك لا يمنعنا ولم يمنعنا عن مواصله هذا
الطريق مهما كان صعب تحدثتي عن نقطه مهمه
جدا وتحول بها في الواقع نجوان التي تجلس
بجانبك جيفارا وهي مقاربه المراه الصحفيه
ليس انتقاسا من قيمه زملائنا في المهنه
فنحن جناحان لطائر الحقيقه كلانا يحلق
عاليا من اجل هذه الحقيقه لكن مقاربه
المراه تحدثت عنها لينسي الصحفيه في
القناه الرابعه وسمعنا اليها من اكثر من
شاهد في الفيلم تبدو مختلفه كيف لمستها
انت نجوان انت كنت قريبه جدا من شيرين
الزميله الصديقه المراه ايضا والانسانه
راينا كيف كان تجاوب العالم مع خبر
استشهادها واغتيالها كيف كانت مقاربتها هي
للعمل الصحفي مما ترك كل هذا الاثر لدى
جمهور عريض من المشاهدين
نعم بدايه شكرا فيروز على هذه الاستضافه
وكل عام ونساء العالم ونساء فلسطين بالف
خير
والعداله لشيرين
يعني شيرين تركت لنا ارثا كبيرا هي مدرسه
في الصحافه كانت ملهمه عندما اخترت هذا
المجال
واخترت مجال الصحافه يعني وانا انظر اليها
وهي تغطي الانتفاضه الاولى وايضا جيفارا
شيرين كما كانت تقول دائما ربما لا نستطيع
ان نغير الواقع ولكن نستطيع تقريب الصوره
من الانسان هذا ربما اكثر ما تعلمته من
شيرين انها كانت دائما تحاول ان تكون
قريبه من الانسان تحديدا في القصه
الفلسطينيه
كان من المهم جدا بالنسبه اليها وبالنسبه
لي ايضا ان نقترب اكثر من الفلسطيني من
قصه
البسيطه من الم ومن معاناه اليوميه من
التفاصيل الحياتيه البسيطه
بعاني منها الفلسطيني في ظل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من زوايا مختلفه من زاويه اكثر
الجانب الانساني انا بالنسبه لي لا توجد
صعوبات اكثر بالنسبه للمراه في هذا العمل
في العمل الصحفي في العمل الميداني
الصعوبات التي تواجهني هي تماما ما تواجه
زميلي الشاب والرجل في الميدان نحن نتعرض
لنفس الظروف اللي نفس
الصعوبات وابرزها في فلسطين لو اردنا ان
نخصها بالذكر هي بطبيعه الحال ان
الجانب الاخر الذي يفترض به ان يحمينا في
الميدان هو نفسه ينظر الينا كاننا اعداء
له ويتعامل معنا على هذا الاساس وهو ما
حدث تم اغتيالها بشكل
مقصود بشكل متعمد بشكل مباشر لان قوات
الاحتلال لا تريد ان نسمع صوتنا وهي تنظر
الينا كعدو في الميدان ولا تميز ابدا كما
لا تميز ابدا بين الشعب الفلسطيني بين
الرجل بين المراه بين المسن بين الطفل بين
المقاوم بين اي شخص اخر هي ايضا لا تفرق
بين كوننا صحفيين وتتعامل معنا على هذا
الاساس وبالتالي هي هذه هي الصعوبه
الرئيسيه التي تواجه
المراه الصحفيه في فلسطين ولكن ايضا الرجل
والشاب في الميدان قد تكون لدينا تحديات
اكبر واحتياجات اكبر ولكن هي ليست صعوبات
على العكس انا اجد بان هناك احتضان اكبر
للمراه في الميدان خاصه في مجتمعنا
الفلسطيني
ربما نحن
من الاهل من العائله من الناس التي نزورها
نعم اتحول هنا الى الاستوديو وظيفاتي
الكريمات في الاستوديو عائشه
وناديه ناديه تحدثت نجوان وجيفارا عن
البيئه التي يعملنا في هديئه الاحتلال
تابعنا قصص ايضا من اليمن عائشه ايضا في
الصومال وجميعها بيئه ربما تجد المراه
العربيه فيها صعوبه انت تعيشين في الغرب
ولدت في فرنسا بلد الحريه بلد الاعلام بلد
الديمقراطيات الذي يدافع ويرفع هذه
الشعارات لكن قصتك ليست مختلفه هناك نوع
من الاضطهاد ايضا هناك نوع من التحديات
التي تواجهينها ماذا لو وضعت المشاهد
الكريم عن نوع هذه التحديات هل هي لكونك
امراه هل هي لكونك
مسلمه هل هي لكونك صحفيه تتطرق للمواضيع
التي توجع خاصه مواضيع التمييز في فرنسا
ام ماذا ام كل هذا ربما
مساء الخير فيروز شكرا جزيلا للدعوه انا
سعيده جدا
لتواجدي معكم ليقدم شهادتي بشان
المسيره المهنيه لقد ذكرتي فرنسا هي ليست
منطقه نزاع ولكن نحن نواجه الكثير من
الصعوبات الاخرى عندما اقول نحن اتحدث
بشكل خاص عن المراه المراه المسلمه المراه
التي تعيش تالقا والتي تلبس الحجاب في
ابريل لقد واصلتني رساله تهديد بالموت
ارسلت الى بيتي من تحت الباب ادخلت الى
بيت اذا ما سمحتي لي اريد ان اقرا هذه
الرساله هذه التهديدات ليست تهديدات فقط
بالموت لشخصي وانما تهديدات هي تستهدف
المجتمع المسلم بفرنسا
انت لا تعرفين انت ليس لديك ولو ادق درجه
ولا ادنى درجه من النفاذ الى فرنسا سنقوم
بطردكم بالجرافات يا عصابه الاسلاميين
وهنا كلمه نابيه استهدف ثلاثه مليون منكم
وهذا هدف معقول
اخرسي وغادري بلدنا ابقي خرقتك التي ستحمل
دماغك وهنا كلمه نابيه انت لا تعرفين
فرنسا لكنك ستعرفين الفرنسيين سنرزور
احياء اللا فرنسا من القبوه او من القبو
الى قويه جدا ناديه يعني نتفاهم انها
رساله تهديد وجهت اليك لكن ماذا كان صداها
في الوسط الاعلامي كيف تعاملت معه كيف
اثرت عليك كصحفيه انت وفي مسيرتك وتقديمك
لرسالتك عالميه
اذا اذكر بالسياقه الذي وصلتني في هذه
الرساله يومين قبل التوصل بالرساله كان
هناك نقاش شاركت فيه في قناه تلفزيونيه
تتابع بشكل كبير جدا وكنت ادافع عن حقي
النساء امهات يستحبن ابنائهن في الزيارات
او الرحلات المدرسيه وهن يلبسنا الحجاب
لان هناك بعض اعضاء البرلمان لا يريدون
بالسماح
وان يرتدين الحجاب وكنت اذكر بمبدا
اللائكيه او العلمانيه كنت اتحدث عن هذا
الالتزام التزام بالحياد ان لهن الحق بان
يخرجنا
يشاركنا مع اطفالهن في مثل هذه الرحلات
الدراسيه لانك تتناولين مثل هذه القضايا
كاعلاميه وربما هي تزهج البعض في المجتمع
الفرنسي
نعم نعم بالطبع لهذا السبب بالضبط
المشكله التي تطرح فيما يتعلق به انا
اتذكر دائما
بدوله القانون ما يجمعنا ما يوحدنا هذه
الامور المتعلقه بالجمهوريه الشيعيار
الجمهوريه حريه مساواه واخاء ونتحدث عن
ميثاق الجمهوري ان يكون هناك
حريه
الدين وكذلك حريه الضمير والوجدان اذا هنا
لا نتحدث عن مجرمين يعيشون دينا معينا لها
لا نحن نتحدث عن خطاب جمهوري وكنا نريد
حقيقه لهذه الاسباب
نريد ان ندعم هذه المراه التي يتم شيطان
شيطنتها وانها مشروع ضد المجتمات تريد ان
تندمج في المجتمع لكنني انا اطالب بما هو
ضد ذلك ان فرنسيه مسلمه البس الحجاب درست
في مدارس الجمهوريه اعرف حقوقي واذكر بها
قصه ربما مختلفه ونحن نحاول ان نتعرف على
قصصكن جميعا عائشه جئتينا من الصومال
الصومال بيئه هشه سياسيا وامنيا لكنك
اثرتي كمراه صوماليه ان تدخل مجال
الاعلامي كيف هي تجربتك ماذا لو اخبرتي
المشاهد الكريم عن نوع الصعوبات التي
تتحدى المراه الصوماليه في هذه البيئه
السياسيه الهشه والامنيه الهشه لكن
المحافظه ايضا
مساء الخير تحيه لك سيده فيروز ولضيوف
الاعزاء ناديه جيفارا وايضا نجوى شكرا
لقناه الجزيره وايضا نطاقم للقصه بقيه على
هذه الحلقه المميزه معاناه الصحفيات
العربيه
العداله ايضا والرحمه
لشهيده شيرين ابو عاقله ولجميع شهداء
الذين قتلوا ظلما في البلدان العربيه
والافريقيه والاسلاميه ايضا
صحيح
مهنه الصحافه اصلا مهنه صعبه وكما يقال هي
اصلا مهنه الموت والمتاعب وخصوصا في هذا
البلد الصومال الذي كان يعاني من حروب
وايضا ونزاعات منذ فتره طويله
ولكن هنالك دوافع
كوني ان اكون اعلاميا في هذا البلد منها
اولا
الرغبه والاراده وشغف الكبير في دخول هذا
المجال
وايضا هناك دافع اخر
الصومال صحيح هو بلد
يعني
عنده مشاكل وحروب ولكن الان
يتعافى تدريجيا وايضا هنالك جانب اخر غير
الذي نراه في الشاشات
فنحتاج الى من يبرز هذا الجانب المشرق
ويسلط الضوء عليه وايضا اهم مدافع هو
ان ادخل في هذا المجال قضايا المراه
كون امراه وايضا اعلاميه ارى ان لدي
مسؤوليه كبيره على عاتقي ان اكون جزء من
تمكين المراه الصوماليه وان يكون لها دور
ومكان في المجتمع تمكنها في الدفاع عن
حقوقها وايضا تحقيق ذاتها
وهل تجد قضايا المراه سبيلها فعلا في
الاعلام الصومالي ماذا عن نسبه مشاركه
الصحفيات من النساء في هذا المشهد
هنالك فرص كثيره
للصحفيات ان يشاركنا في هذا المجال ولكن
ليست كثيره وايضا قضايا هن قضايا المراه
عموما او لا لا تحظى بتقضيه مناسبه بالقدر
المطلوب فهنالك دوما
في قضايا المراه
التكلم فيها والتعمق فيها في اطار محدود
ربما من المجتمع او هذه الاسباب جاءت من
المجتمع او ايضا من البيئه من السياسات
التحريريه للوسائل الاعلاميه فمثلا هنالك
صديقه
اخبرتني منذ ايام انها كانت تعد تقريرا عن
تحديات بموضوع تحديات العمل تحديات او في
المراه التي تواجه المراه في بيئه العمل
واثناء خلال بحثها واعدادها لهذا التقرير
فوجئت
بالقاء التقرير
مديرها التحريري قرر فجاه ان يلقي هذا
التقرير وهو ايضا ينكر وجود اصلا تلك
التحديات في بيئه العمل اذا هي هي صعوبات
تجدها المراه الصوماليه اضافه لهذه البيئه
الهشه السياسيا وامنيا ربما المجتمع ايضا
لا ينصف المراه الصوماليه بشكل كبير اعود
الى فلسطين وايقوناتنا هناك جيفارا
ونجوان يعني جيفارا انت شاهدناك المشاهد
العربي وحتى نجوان في مرات عديده كيف
يعتدي عليكم جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نوع
المضايقات التي تتعرضنا لها ربما هذا هو
الجزء الطافي فقط من جبل الجليد ماذا لو
اخبرتنا عن يعني نوع
الظلم والظلم الذي يقع عليكن كمراسلات
اثناء التغطيه كن والذي ربما لا تتمكن
الكاميرات في كثير من الاحيان من نقله
يعني اولها بالطبع هو محاوله الثبات
استمداد القوه بعدم اظهار اي نوع من الخوف
او الضعف هذا بكون التحدي الاول في العمل
في الميدان في اوضاع صعبه يعني انا
ساذكرون يعني انتم شاهدتونا الان انا
ونجوان قاعدين نطلع نشاهد التلفون لانه
هناك احداث متسارعه في بلده حواره قبل
يومين نحن كنا في حواره في ساعات المساء
اصبحنا في النصف انا والطاقم رمضان وزميلي
عبد الله بين المستوطن وبين جنود الاحتلال
انت في الميدان كما ذكرت نجوان
نحن اعداء فقط نحن عدو جديد
والان يمكن عدو اكبر للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
والمستوطنين في نقل الحقيقه كنا في النصف
بين هؤلاء المستوطنين هؤلاء الجنود الذين
لا يريدون نقل الصوره لا ي نقل الحقيقه
ولكن يجب ان نكون ثابتين عنا قوه داخليه
رغم انه احيانا نحن بشر يمكن ان نخاف
ما حدث يعني نجوان تعرضت للاعتداء في
الشيخ جراح في مناطق اخرى تعرضنا للاعتداء
المباشر في الشيخ جراح ولكن اريد ان اذكر
هنا مثل بسيط
لاوضح ما معنى الصعوبه ان تكوني امراه في
الميدان في فلسطين رغم قلت لك واعيد واكرر
البيئه الخاصه للمراه الفلسطينيه التي
تعمل في كل المجالات المراه الفلسطينيه لا
يصعب عليها شيء لان هذا هو المجتمع
الفلسطيني ولكن ايضا وهي تتعامل مع هذا
القدر يعني بكون اتمنى يعرفوا اني انا
بشتغل
نعم ولكن هي بناتي بخافوا يشوفوا بخافوا
يشوفوا وانا بكون خايفه انهم يشوفوا الان
نحن نقول جمله واحده ان اردت ان تهدي هديه
لصحفي او لضابط اسعاف اعطيه موعد مع طبيب
نفسي الصحه النفسيه ايضا هي جزء صعب جدا
نحن نحاول ان يعني ان نتعايش مع كل هذه
الظروف الان نحن نعيش بعد شيرين 22 23 سنه
من الذكريات الصعبه من القصص الصعبه التي
عشناها هي ايضا في جزء من ذاكرتنا ولكن
هذا يعطينا يعني دافع اقوى عندما نقول
اننا نغطي قضايا الاسرى الاسرى هم شهداء
مع وقف التنفيذ عندما نستمع لذويهم نحاول
ان نتبع اخبارهم في هذه الايام ان نصل
اننا مضطرون لنتحدث ان نفسر اشياء كتير
بسيطه انه الان يسمح للاسير في سجون
الاحتلال ان يستح فقط الاربع دقائق لن
يفهم المشاهد بشكل عادي طبيعي خارج فلسطين
ماذا يعني استحمام لاربع دقائق ان لا يحصل
على الخبز مقومات الحياه فقط للوجود على
الحياه هل هذه امور طبيعيه هل هذه بالامور
البسيطه هي ليست بالامور مره اخرى
عن حياتك وعن يعني تاثر مجرد احتلال
نسالك عن حياتك وعن التحديات لك كما في
فلسطين وتؤثرين مره اخرى ان تتحدث عن
الاسرى وعن مشاكلهم وهذا هو الصلب عمل
الصحفي في الواقع هو صاحب رساله لكنك اشرت
الى نقطه مهمه اتحول بها الى نجوان هذا
الصحفي الذي نريد ان نراه بطلا هو انسان
في نهايه الامر ذكرتي جزئيه الجانب النفسي
كيف يتاثر بالبيئه المحيطه به باستشهاد
زملائه للاسف التغطيه مستمره دائما وفي
فلسطين اكثر واكثر لم تعطونا حتى فرصه
ربما ان يحزن الانسان ان يتوقف مع كثير من
الماس التي تحدث في فلسطين واسال هنا
نجوان كيف يؤثر ذلك على نفسيه
الصحفيات العاملات في فلسطين
يعني انا شخصيا اتاثر كثيرا يعني شخصيتي
هي انني اتاثر كثيرا باي قصه انسانيه اقوم
بتغطيتها يعني عندما ازور ناس يتم هدم
منزلهم اتاثر كثيرا عندما اذكر انني عندما
غطيت في بدايه عملي كمراسله في الجزيره
قصه الطفل دوابشي الذي احرق المنزل
واحرقت عائلته من قبل المستوطنين يعني
احجمت عن الطعام ليومين لم استطع ان
اتناول الطعام بعد ان زرته في المستشفى
وقابلته يعني انا شخصيا اتاثر كثيرا من
المفضل ربما ان الصحفي لا يبدي هذا التاثر
ربما اصعب قضيه غطيتها وبدات اشعر بنوع من
التحول في هذا العمل الصحفي هو اغتيال
شيرين على عده مستويات المستوى الاول انا
يعني في الميدان لا اشعر بالخوف وهذا ربما
ايضا بالنسبه لي يشكل مشكله لانني لا اشعر
بحجم الخوف الذي اكون بداخله لو كان هناك
مستوطنين او لو كان هناك
جنود الاحتلال كل همي يكون هو نقل الصوره
ونقل القضيه لكن بدات اكثر افكر بان من
يقف امامي
سيستسهل باي لحظه ان يطلق الرصاص عليه هذا
حدث بعد اغتيال
ثانيا انا وشيرين كنا مقربات جدا وكانت
لدينا محادثه يوميه بعد انتهاء يوم العمل
انا في القدس وهي عاده في رام الله نتحدث
عما واجهناه خلال هذا النهار دائما كل
الصعوبات التي كانت تواجهني خلال العمل
سواء كان مشاكل تقنيه ضغوط عمل اخبار وانت
تعرفين هذا المجال فيروز اذكر دائما كيف
كانت تقول يلا بتهون يوم وبمشي واكيد
عملتي تقرير حلو انا افتقد لكل هذه
اللحظات مع شيرين والنقطه الثالثه بدات
افكر بعد اغتيال شيرين
ما هي الجدوى من العمل الصحفي اذا كنا لا
نستطيع ان نحقق عدالتها اذا كان الجاني لن
يتعاقب بمعنى مهمه جدا
اليها ونحن نؤكد عليها دائما نجوان وهي
عدم ولا يعاقب هذا الجاني صحيح يا نجوان
لا يجب اطلاقا ان يفلت القاتل بفعلته وهذا
اكثر ما فعلقني اذا كنت صحيح صحيح لقد
تكون لنا عوده لكن دعيني اعود مره اخرى
لناديه هنا ناديه الصحفيات ايضا
يتعرضن ليس فقط في الواقع هناك تحرش على
الانترنت هناك تهديدات ايضا كما حدث معك
باعتقادك ان كانت فرنسا او حتى اوروبا او
العالم الحر الغربي لا يقدم اي نوع من
الضمانات للحمايه ما الذي يمكن ان نامل
نحن في المنطقه العربيه ما الذي يمنع من
تفعيل هذه القوانين والتشريعات الكبيره
التي يفترض ان تحمل صحفيه في الغرب
انا طلبت الحمايه من الشرطه طلبت ذلك من
رئيس الدوله
ومستشاره الامني رد علي
الجميع الجميع بما في ذلك الاتحاد ونقابه
الصحفيين وكذلك الجهات الموجوده في
وزاره الداخليه وقالوا ان التهديدات ليست
تهديدات جديه وهم اخذوا الرساله من اجل
دراستها من اجل تحليلها وبعد ذلك بعد
شهرين وصلتني رساله اخرى الى بيتي والتي
كانت
تقوم بسبي وكانت طابع عنصري
ومره اخرى طلبوا مني ان اغادر وهذه
الرساله الثانيه بطريقه نفسها
الى تدخل هذه الجهات في اقل من دقيقه
واريد ان اختم عائشه لان وقتنا قرب على
الانتهاء رسالتك انت رساله الصحفيات
الصوماليات التي قلت بان البعض حملك اياها
وانت قادمه هنا الى الجزيره
شكرا السيده فيروز اريد ان استغل هذه
الفرصه
ابلغ هذه الرساله
كما ذكرت سابقا الصومال بدا يتعافى وله
ايضا جانب مشرق نريد ان نحتاج ان
نعرف الناس العالم اجمع
بقصص الصومال الايجابيه
ولهذا نحتاج الى صحفيات
وكوادر ايضا مؤهله لهذا العمل ايضا نحتاج
الى تدوير وتنميه
والتدريب مجال نتمنى ذلك اتمنى ان يلقى
هذا النداء فعلا استجابه ممن يهمه الامر
اشكرك جزيل الشكر عائشه لاحمد للاسف وقتنا
انتهى تماما ناديه العزوني كما اشكر
الزميلتين جيفارا المدير و نجوان سمري
كانت معنا من رام الله ختام وحلقتنا هذه
من برنامج القصه بقيه كل عام وكل نساء
العالم بالف خير والصحفيات تحديدا بالف
خير السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]